.
* Ein Hahn kräht. *
Schon als Kind haben sie
davon geträumt, Tierärzte zu werden.
Dafür müssen die Welschen
fürs Studium nach Bern.
An der Uni sassen sie meist
über den Büchern
und hatten kaum mit Tieren zu tun.
Jetzt müssen sie rund um die Uhr
für einen Einsatz bereit sein.
Der Berufsalltag ist hart:
24 Std., sieben Tage.
Darum wird jede und jeder Vierte
den Traumberuf wieder aufgeben.
Wir haben drei junge Tierärzte
begleitet:
Gwennaëlle
macht eine Spezialausbildung
für neuartige Haustiere und arbeitet
in einer Praxis im Kanton Waadt.
* Fröhliche Musik *
William macht ein Volontariat
in der Notfallstation
des Berner Tierspitals.
Im hochmodernen Spital
hat er mit kritischen
und hoffnungslosen Fällen zu tun.
Eléonore hat sich
den Kühen verschrieben
und arbeitet als Landtierärztin
in Porrentruy.
Es ist ein anstrengender Beruf
und man weiss im Voraus nie,
wie lange der Tag wird.
Und das sind sie:
unsere jungen Tierärzte.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Musik aus dem Autoradio *
Musik auf dem Weg zur Arbeit,
und Eléonore ist glücklich.
Sie ist 26
und arbeitet seit ihrem Abschluss
als Landtierärztin in Porrentruy.
Sie ist auf dem Weg
zu einer hinkenden Kuh.
Morgen, Dominique.
- Salut.
Wie geht's?
- Gut, und dir? - Gut, danke.
Gehen wir zur Kuh.
- Ja.
Eine meiner Kühe hinkt.
Ich hoffte,
es gehe von allein vorbei.
Ich habe die Klauen
selber verbunden.
Aber es wurde nicht besser.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Komm! So.
Die Kuh bockt. Aber das beeindruckt
Eléonore nicht sonderlich.
Komm schon.
Geht etwas?
Hü!
Endlich gibt Juliette nach
und die Untersuchung kann anfangen.
Als Erstes muss die Hornschicht
der Klauen abgefeilt werden.
* Muhen *
Sie steht fast nicht mehr drauf.
Wir sind es uns gewohnt,
dass die Kühe ab und zu krank sind.
Aber man sorgt sich trotzdem.
Siehst du etwas?
- Ja, hier ist ein Loch.
Je tiefer ich schabe.
Ja.
- Es ist ziemlich tief, das Ding.
Das grosse Loch ist ein Abszess.
Die Infektion
geht zum Hufansatz und oben raus.
Juliette leidet.
Abszesse sind sehr schmerzhaft.
Ich muss hier
möglichst viel aufschneiden,
damit alles abfliessen kann
und der Eiter nicht zurückbleibt.
Ja, du Gute. Ich gebe dir
etwas gegen die Entzündung.
Ja, ich weiss,
du hast keine Lust mehr.
Ah! Yes!
Dein Timing ist grossartig, Kuh.
Wirklich.
Jetzt gibt es eine kleine Hilfe,
damit Juliette beim Draufstehen
keine Schmerzen mehr hat.
* Eléonore summt. *
Mit dieser Stütze
unter der gesunden Sohle
wird die kranke Klaue
beim Laufen nicht belastet.
Das Gewicht wird verlagert und die
Kuh steht nicht mehr auf die Klaue.
So sollte sie nicht mehr lahmen.
Ja, wir sind bald fertig.
- Ja, meine Liebe.
Du hattest Geduld.
In der Schule lernt man viel,
aber in der Praxis kommt viel dazu.
Das war nicht meine erste Klaue.
Beim ersten Mal
war ich nicht so effizient.
Trotz des neuen Fusses
wird Juliette langsam ungeduldig.
Gibt es eine intravenöse Spritze?
Können wir machen, ja.
Wird sie hinhalten?
Das werden wir sehen.
Dominique lässt den Fuss runter,
dann gibt es eine Spritze.
Warum hat sie Schmerzen?
Wegen des Medikamentes?
- Ja, zu Beginn brennt es.
So, du Liebe. Fertig.
Kühe sind sehr anhänglich.
Sie sind viel intelligenter,
als man meint.
Sie sind sympathisch
und haben einen eigenen Charakter.
Jede hat ihre guten
und weniger guten Seiten,
die sie
von den anderen unterscheidet.
Eine Kuh ist einfach süss.
Ein 30-minütiger Eingriff,
und das Ganze ist erledigt.
Dominique ist überzeugt.
Ich wusste, dass sie dynamisch ist,
wir vertrauen ihr. Sie macht's gut.
Dominique. Bis nächstes Mal.
- Salut, bis dann.
Es ist erst 8.30 Uhr, Eléonore
hat einen langen Tag vor sich.
Im Tierspital Bern hat auch William
seinen Arbeitstag begonnen.
Seit dem Uniabschluss arbeitet er
als Praktikant in der Notfallstation,
wo er von Chefärztin Katja
begleitet wird.
Dieser kleine Mops
kam aus dem Wallis nach Bern.
Es ist Colpo.
Er ist ein richtiger Sofa-Hund.
Er bewegt sich praktisch nicht.
Er ist ruhig, sozial.
Komm, wir setzen uns.
Der Hund ist extrem anhänglich,
wie eine Klette.
Ich wollte ihn nicht "pot de colle",
Klette, nennen,
darum habe ich es umgedreht: Colpo.
Er hat Mühe mit Atmen.
Der Tierarzt sagte aber:
"Sofort ins Tierspital."
Er hat die ganze Nacht schlecht
geschlafen und konnte kaum atmen.
Schauen Sie, er atmet ruckartig.
So stossweise, das ist nicht gut.
Okay, ich hole Sie gleich
im Wartezimmer ab.
Für William ist klar:
Atemprobleme sind immer ein Notfall.
Man muss so schnell wie möglich
rausfinden, wo das Problem ist.
Am meisten Sorgen
bereitet William das Herz.
Der Herzschlag ist nicht normal,
darum macht er einen Ultraschall.
Um sein Herz
hat sich Flüssigkeit angesammelt,
die in den Herzbeutel dringt und
den Herzschlag stark beeinträchtigt.
Das ist nicht normal,
er kann jeden Moment dekompensieren,
dann könnte sein Herz stillstehen.
Colpo ist in Lebensgefahr. William
muss der Besitzerin Bescheid geben.
Bei der Untersuchung
habe ich gesehen,
dass der rechte Herzvorhof
diese Bewegung macht.
Was ist ein Herzvorhof?
- Das Herz besteht aus vier Teilen.
Oben zwei Herzvorhöfe
und unten die Herzkammern.
Der rechte Vorhof macht Probleme.
Der Herzschlag
sollte wie eine Pumpe sein.
Stattdessen macht es ...
Sein aktueller Zustand zeigt,
dass man das Problem
ernst nehmen muss.
William schlägt vor, mit einer Nadel
Flüssigkeit abzupumpen,
damit Colpos Herz
wieder normal schlagen kann.
Ist er danach wieder wie neu?
- Vielleicht nicht ganz neu.
Das wäre wunderbar.
Aber erst muss die Flüssigkeit
aus dem Herz.
Anne-Marie ist besorgt.
... einfach auf die Seite legen -
das geht garantiert nicht.
Wir geben eine Beruhigungsspritze.
- Ja, ja.
* Spannende Musik *
Ganz kurz, ganz kurz.
Da ist einer ...
- ... der sich nicht legen lässt.
Aber willst du ihn
liegend punktieren?
Auf der linken Seite, ja.
* Piepsen *
Versuchen wir hier, langsam.
Ist gut, Kleiner.
- Schsch ...
Colpo will einfach nicht liegen.
Jetzt muss William den Eingriff
in dieser ungünstigen Position
durchführen.
Wir schauen noch
auf der anderen Seite.
Hallo, kannst du uns
bei der Perikardiozentese helfen?
Katja holt Verstärkung.
Zum Glück gibt es im Spital
einen Tierkardiologen.
William muss
wegen eines anderen Notfalls weg.
Ich bekam die Meldung
von einem weiteren Notfall.
Ein Chihuahua
sei von irgendwo runtergefallen.
Es gehe ihm sehr schlecht.
Was ist das für ein Notfall?
Es geht um einen Chihuahua,
der aus den Händen gefallen ist.
Alles klar.
Ich sollte ihn untersuchen.
Wir haben aber
einen lebensbedrohlichen Fall.
Gut, bis gleich.
So, schauen wir uns dich an.
Jetzt muss es schnell gehen.
Auf dem Nebentisch trägt Colpo
bereits die Sauerstoffmaske.
Die Flüssigkeit
muss dringend abgepumpt werden.
Zum Glück ist dem Chihuahua
nichts Schlimmes passiert.
Der Zustand war stabil.
Darum habe ich ihn zurückgebracht.
Ich erklärte, dass wir einen Notfall
haben, das haben sie verstanden.
Im Notfall
muss man Prioritäten setzen.
Als er zurückkommt,
hat sich Katja umentschieden.
Ist es okay, wenn Alan das macht?
- Ja, eh.
Gut, dann soll er es machen.
Willst du es machen?
Es ist egal.
- Nein, sag, was du willst.
Ich kann es schon machen ...
- Gut, dann machen wir es.
Eine grosse Herausforderung
für William.
Sind die anderen stabil?
- Ja.
Die Assistenzärzte müssen zeigen,
dass sie alles im Griff haben.
Die Vorgesetzten testen ständig.
Alan ist ein erfahrener Kardiologe
und will wissen, welche Instrumente
William brauchen will.
... wie du es machst.
Ich würde es damit machen.
Dann mach es mit dem.
Aber das Risiko besteht,
dass es abknickt.
Richtig.
Dann machen wir es damit.
Aber das Risiko ist ...
... geringer.
- Ja. Gut, machen wir es so.
William muss die Flüssigkeit rund
um das Herz mit einer Nadel absaugen.
Das macht er zum ersten Mal.
Man gibt ihm vor,
wie es etwa funktioniert.
Sie haben es ja schon mal gesehen.
Jetzt müssen sie es
in die Praxis umsetzen
und im Prinzip
die Nadel selber führen.
Man ist immer dabei.
Man guckt direkt, was sie machen.
Man könnte jederzeit eingreifen,
wenn es nicht gut läuft.
William weiss:
Er darf keinen Fehler machen.
In dem Moment
denkt man nichts anderes.
Man überlegt, was man machen muss.
Sonst ist nichts mehr im Kopf,
nur noch das Tier, die Nadel.
That's it.
Eine falsche Bewegung
und Colpos Herz hört auf zu schlagen.
* Pulsierende Klänge *
* Fröhliche Musik *
In Rolle im Kanton Waadt kontrolliert
Gwennaëlle mit ihrer Chefin
die Termine des heutigen Tages.
Die frisch diplomierte Tierärztin
arbeitet vier Monate
in dieser Praxis.
Grüezi.
Würden Sie das bitte ausfüllen?
Ich heisse Marjorie Panchaud,
ich wohne
in Saint-Saphorin-sur-Morges.
Ich bin mit meinem Kaninchen Sissi
hergekommen.
Sissi hat eine schlimme Woche
hinter sich.
Sie fiel in ihrem Gehege
ganz blöd herunter,
sodass man ihre Hinterpfote
amputieren musste.
Das passiert bei Hasen oft,
weil sie schnell Panik bekommen.
Wie ist das passiert?
- Sie hatte Panik.
Ich war nicht dabei,
ich hörte nur einen Knall.
Kaninchen sind Beutetiere.
Sie sind sehr empfindlich
auf Geräusche, Gerüche oder Stress.
Wenn eine Katze oder ein Hund
im Haus sind, spüren sie das sofort.
In der Natur
bedrohen solche Tiere ihr Leben.
Heute Morgen schleckte sie die Wunde
ab, bis sie aufgegangen ist.
Wir haben sie mit sechs Wundklammern
geschlossen,
aber am Abend haben zwei gefehlt,
wohl abgerissen.
Dann haben Sie sie
nicht mehr gefunden?
Vielleicht hat sie sie verschluckt
oder abgerissen.
Das müssen wir erst herausfinden.
Haben Sie die Wundklammern gefunden?
- Nein. Ich habe sie nicht gesucht.
Vielleicht hat sie sie verschluckt.
- Ich hoffe nicht.
Marjorie kennt sich mit Hasen aus.
Sie hat 20 von den süssen Tieren.
Ich kümmere mich
um ausgesetzte Kaninchen.
Sissi kommt zu einem neuen Besitzer?
- Ja.
Ich hatte bereits
einen Interessenten.
Aber dann ist der Unfall passiert.
Ob Sissi mit ihrem Handicap
doch noch ein neues Zuhause findet?
Zuerst kümmert sich Gwennaëlle
so gut es geht um die Wunde.
Ich putze die Wundränder und versu-
che es mit einer intrakutanen Naht.
Ich hoffe, das funktioniert.
Aber Klammern
würde sie wieder wegreissen.
Und morgen bin ich wieder da.
- Genau.
Wundklammern machen keinen Sinn.
Ich brauche eine andere Lösung,
weil jedes Tier anders reagiert.
Unsere Aufgabe ist es,
herauszufinden, was das Beste ist.
Wird es richtig kleben?
Ja, die Wunde soll geschlossen sein
und es darf keine Fäden geben.
Sonst reisst sie sie auch ab.
Können Sie kurz warten?
Eine Katze, die ich behandle,
ist eben eingeschlafen.
Möchten Sie Wasser oder Kaffee?
- Ja, gerne Kaffee.
So.
- Merci.
Ich lasse Sie kurz allein.
Sie dürfen auch
ins Wartezimmer gehen.
Rufen Sie mich, wenn etwas ist.
Bis gleich.
Merci.
Sissi muss noch warten,
bis sie an der Reihe ist.
Während sie im Wartezimmer
verwöhnt wird,
klingelt in der Praxis Ajovet im Jura
schon wieder das Telefon.
Tierpraxis Ajovet, Camille, grüezi.
Es gibt ein Problem
mit der Geburt eines Lamms.
Ich schicke Ihnen jemanden vorbei.
Hat jemand angerufen?
Ja, Herr Caillet.
Er braucht deine Hilfe.
Mit dem Schaf stimmt etwas nicht.
Ein Mutterschaf
sollte ein Lamm gebären.
Sie hat vor 1 Std.
das Fruchtwasser verloren.
Ciao.
- Tschüss.
In einem solchen Fall
fahre ich sofort los.
Alles andere kann warten,
das ist fast ein Notfall.
Beim Ablammen muss es schnell gehen.
Die Lämmchen sind sehr empfindlich
und können bei der Geburt sterben.
Darum mache ich mich sofort
auf den Weg.
* Dramatische Musik *
Die Fahrt dauert 45 Min.
Jede Minute zählt.
* Blöken *
Gerard ist besorgt um seine Cerise.
Er ist pensioniert
und kümmert sich um seine 22 Schafe,
die ihm die Obstwiese abgrasen.
Am Mittag sah ich, dass sie
das Fruchtwasser verloren hatte.
Als ich nach gut 1 Std.
nochmals nachschaute,
war die Position zwar gut,
aber das Lamm kam nicht raus.
Das gibt es ab und zu,
dass etwas schiefgeht.
Aber wenn man zu lange wartet,
kann das Junge sterben.
Oder es passiert sonst etwas.
Auf dem Weg
spielte ich alle Varianten durch.
Ich fragte mich, was ist,
wenn ich die Klauen nicht finde,
wenn es bereits tot ist
oder wenn es verkehrt herum liegt
und ich es nicht wenden kann.
Endlich ist Eléonore da.
Oh, man sieht bereits die Schnauze.
Ja, aber sonst bewegt sich nichts.
Dir muss man nur
ein wenig nachhelfen.
Eléonore versucht,
an den Vorderbeinen zu ziehen,
aber das Lamm ist blockiert.
Man sieht die Schnauze.
- Ja, seit ich angerufen habe.
Mit Lamm-Geburten hat Eléonore
noch nicht viel Erfahrung.
Wir haben nur wenige Kunden,
die Schafe halten.
Das war wohl mein viertes Schaf,
das ich auf die Welt zu bringen
versuchte. Das ist wenig.
Eléonore wird langsam unruhig
und kontrolliert die Lage des Lamms.
Das Problem war,
dass die Ellbogen angewinkelt waren.
So ist es unmöglich,
durch das Becken zu kommen.
Der Kopf und die beiden gebogenen
Vorderbeine - das passt nicht.
Seit fast 1 Std. sitzt das ungeborene
Lamm in dieser Position fest.
Um Hilfe zu holen, ist es zu spät.
Wenn es Eléonore nicht schafft,
die Beine zu strecken,
könnten das Junge und die Mutter
sterben.
* Blöken *
Auf der Notfallstation
des Tierspitals Bern
herrscht Konzentration.
Ein erfahrener Kardiologe
hilft William,
die Flüssigkeit zu punktieren, die
sich um Colpos Herz angesammelt hat.
Hast du gemessen,
wie tief du gehen darfst?
Ca. 3 cm.
Das haben wir halbwegs.
Colpo wurde nur leicht betäubt.
Die geringste Bewegung
könnte fatale Folgen haben.
Dass sich das Tier bewegt,
macht es schwierig.
Man ist mit der Nadel
direkt beim Herz.
Bei einer Bewegung könnte die Nadel
zu tief oder woandershin gehen.
Dadurch könnten wir
eine Herzrhythmusstörung auslösen,
was zum Tod führt.
Penetriert hast du da sicher.
Du siehst, es wird immer mehr
im Pleuraraum, weniger im Perikard.
Das war komplex,
aber nicht unmöglich.
Gut, geschafft.
- Gut. Dann gehen wir.
William kann aufatmen.
Der Eingriff wirkt sofort.
Colpos Herz
schlägt bereits wieder normal.
Jetzt darf William die gute Nachricht
Anne-Marie überbringen.
Wir legen ihn hierhin,
so kann er in Ruhe aufwachen.
Sobald er wach ist,
kommt der Venenzugang weg.
Dann dürfen Sie nach Hause.
Wir haben die Flüssigkeit
abgelassen,
die sich ums Herz angesammelt hat.
Er ist beduselt und atmet komisch,
aber das Herz schlägt wieder besser.
Oh, bist du schwer.
Komm her.
* Schnarchen *
Hoffentlich schläft er heute Nacht.
Sonst habe ich ein Herzproblem
aus Angst, ob er noch atmet.
Das ist anstrengend.
Komm, steh hin.
Komm! Komm, wir gehen.
Hey, Colpo! Komm.
Wir gehen nach Hause.
Herrje.
Langsam kommt Leben
in den kleinen Mops.
Auch wenn er noch nicht versteht,
wo er überhaupt ist.
So.
- Sehr gut.
Wenn etwas ist, rufen Sie an.
- Ja, vielen Dank.
Bereits kommt der nächste Notfall.
Ein Tierarzt
schickte Leo ins Tierspital,
weil er vermutlich
das hoch ansteckende Parvovirus hat.
Leo muss sofort isoliert werden, er
ist eine Gefahr für das ganze Spital.
Wir haben ihn erst seit ... Samstag.
Er hat nichts gefressen,
er war schlapp.
Und er hatte Durchfall.
Er hat weder gefressen
noch getrunken.
Grüezi.
Entschuldigen Sie die Handschuhe.
Wir befürchten, dass sich
das Virus im Spital ausbreitet.
Es ist hochinfektiös,
darum schützen wir uns.
Damit wir uns nicht anstecken.
Sonst könnten wir selber
Überträger werden.
Darum ziehen wir Handschuhe,
Schuhüberzieher und eine Schürze an.
Er ist zehn Wochen alt,
wir haben ihn seit Samstag.
Die Züchter wissen nicht,
was los ist.
Bei einem Welpen
wird einem schon warm ums Herz.
Er ist sehr anhänglich.
Er musste husten,
und es kam Schaum aus seinem Mund.
Ist er gegen das Parvovirus geimpft?
Ich glaube.
Wissen Sie, wann er geimpft wurde?
- Nein.
Ich werde ihn kurz untersuchen.
Hat er Schmerzen?
Gestern hatte er Bauchschmerzen.
Es hat gegrummelt im Bauch.
Im Sommer haben wir öfters Fälle,
weil die Leute
aus den Ferien heimkommen.
Sie kommen aus Madrid, Portugal,
waren auf dem Markt,
wo sie von einem Hund
süss angeschaut wurden.
Sie sagten sich:
"Komm, den kaufen wir."
Der Hund war aber mit 150 anderen
in einem Zwinger, ohne Impfungen.
Das macht Probleme.
Auf solche Probleme
ist Simone nicht vorbereitet.
Sie kaufte ihren Hund
bei einem Schweizer Züchter.
William nimmt eine Blutprobe,
die sofort anzeigt,
ob Leo infiziert ist.
Er bekommt Antibiotika.
Das grösste Risiko des Parvovirus
ist eine Sepsis.
Blutvergiftung?
- Genau.
Erste Komplikationen
stellt man oft im Darm fest.
Dann muss operiert werden,
weil das Virus eine Dehydration
oder eine Blutvergiftung
auslösen könnte.
Beides könnte zum Tod führen.
Wir sind verpflichtet, die Leute
auf das Schlimmste vorzubereiten,
weil wir nie wissen, wie es ausgeht.
Es kann gut gehen, aber auch nicht.
... wenn er etwas hat,
ist es besser für ihn, wenn er ...
Leo muss im Spital bleiben,
in einem Isolationsraum.
Das ist für Simone hart.
Wir hätten schon dafür gesorgt,
dass er nicht allein ist.
Er ist nicht allein.
- Ohne Rudel, ganz allein.
Er ist nicht ständig allein,
das wäre nicht gut.
Wir haben Tierpfleger.
Sie gehen mit ihnen raus.
Sie kümmern sich um sie.
Draussen gibt es einen Ort,
wo man trotz Infektion hin kann.
William schafft es nicht,
Simone aufzumuntern.
Sie hat grosse Mühe, ihren
kleinen Leo allein zurückzulassen.
Ja, das ist sehr schwierig.
Er sollte jetzt eigentlich
bei uns sein, bei unserem Rudel.
Sie hat den Hund
noch nicht einmal eine Woche.
Aber man hängt trotzdem an ihnen.
Wenn man einen Welpen kauft,
möchte man ihn bei sich haben.
Dann sagt der Arzt,
der Hund müsse im Spital bleiben.
Ich bin seit Samstag
mit ihm zusammen.
Ich war immer mit ihm zusammen.
Er hat eine Box zum Schlafen,
meine Matratze war nebenan.
So war er nicht allein.
Wenn ich nur kurz in den Keller gehe
und wieder hoch, weint er schon.
Er ist ein Baby.
Der kleine Leo wird für ein paar Tage
völlig isoliert.
* Melancholische Musik *
* Hoffnungsvolle Musik *
In Rolle untersucht Gwennaëlle Sissi.
Dem Hasen wurde nach einem Sturz
ein Bein amputiert.
Jetzt ist die Wunde aufgerissen.
Von den sechs Wundklammern
konnte sie zwei wegreissen.
Das ist ein Ort,
an den sie gut hinkommt.
Wollen wir sie mit Gas betäuben?
- Ja, ich glaube auch.
Das ist am einfachsten.
- Ja, klar.
Wir haben uns
für eine Gasnarkose entschieden.
Den Kopf runter, Schätzchen.
Du machst es gut. Runtergehen.
Das Kaninchen atmet das Gas ein
und schläft sofort ein.
Er hat keinen Stress
und wacht schnell wieder auf.
Das Gas
wird schnell wieder ausgeschieden.
Es braucht eine Wundertechnik,
damit sie nicht wieder alles frisst.
Wenn man den Spezialisten zuschaut,
sieht Nähen einfach aus.
Das ist es aber nicht.
Ich habe es so gelernt,
dass mir die Tierärztin
einen Fensterputzlappen gab.
Sie machte einen Schnitt rein,
gab mir Nadel und Faden und sagte:
"Näh das zusammen."
Sie erklärte mir, wie es geht,
ich übte am Lappen.
Manchmal nahm ich auch
eine Bananenschale.
Es ist nicht einfach.
Noch schwieriger ist es,
wenn die Tierbesitzerin zuschaut.
Aber Gwennaëlle
gibt sich möglichst cool.
Wenn du diesen Faden ausreissen
willst, musst du lange suchen.
Ich bin Mitglied im Verein
La colline aux lapins.
Wir nehmen Kaninchen auf,
die die Leute nicht mehr wollen.
Solche, die man z.B.
an Weihnachten bekommt?
Ja, oder an Ostern.
Aber wir bekommen sie
aus diversen Gründen das ganze Jahr,
z.B. bei einem Umzug.
Und jetzt
bekommt sie ein neues Pyjama,
damit sie nicht an die Naht kommt.
Gefällt es Ihnen?
Hauptsache,
sie kommt nicht mehr ran.
Ich bin sehr zufrieden.
Die Arbeit wurde gut gemacht.
Sie darf jetzt in den Käfig.
- Soll ich sie nehmen?
Sissis Familie
wollte sie adoptieren.
Sie nehmen sie trotzdem,
obwohl sie eine Pfote weniger hat.
Das berührt mich sehr.
Aber wirklich beruhigt
bin ich erst nächste Woche.
Wenn die Wunde verheilt
und alles gut ist.
* Muhen *
Im Jura ist Eléonore
immer noch daran,
das Junge aus dem Bauch
des Mutterschafs zu holen.
Schafhalter Gerard ist besorgt.
Ich hänge an meinen Tieren.
Wenn es ein Problem gibt,
rufe ich die Tierärztin.
Meine Schafe sollen nicht leiden,
ich hole jeweils sofort Hilfe.
Die Vorderbeine des Lamms
sind gebogen,
darum kommt es nicht
durch das Becken.
Es ist rutschig.
* Das Schaf blökt. *
Es geht nicht mehr nach Lehrbuch.
Eléonore bestreicht sich
mit Desinfektionsmittel.
Ich arbeite immer möglichst sauber,
darum ziehe ich Handschuhe an.
Aber dadurch schlüpften mir
die Vorderfüsse aus den Händen.
Ich konnte sie nicht packen.
Um sie besser greifen zu können,
zog ich die Handschuhe aus.
Wir bringen es raus.
* Das Schaf blökt. *
Voilà.
Die Ellbogen sind gebogen.
Es ist gut. Es ist gut. Es ist gut.
Sehr gut, voilà.
He, komm!
Komm noch etwas runter.
So, sehr gut.
* Beschwingte Musik *
So, geht's gut?
Das Lamm lebt, und Eléonore
strahlt vor Erleichterung.
Ui, ui, ui. Ich lege es hier hin.
* Blöken *
Ja, das ist deins.
Kümmere dich darum.
Das ist das Schönste an meinem
Beruf: Tiere zur Welt bringen.
Es ist wunderbar zu sehen,
wie das Kalb auf die Mutter zugeht
und es dank uns lebt -
dieses Gefühl vergisst man nie mehr.
Das macht meinen Beruf magisch.
Was ist los?
Nicht mich musst du ablecken.
Hier ist es. Hier.
Das Junge ist gesund und munter,
und Gerard ist erleichtert.
Er ist froh, dass es der Mutter
gut geht und das Junge lebt.
Er zeigt es nicht so.
Das ist halt so.
Bei Bauern und solchen,
die Nutztiere halten.
Sie machen keine Komplimente
oder Freudensprünge.
Aber ich sehe,
dass sie zufrieden sind.
Also, bis zum nächsten Mal.
- Bis zum nächsten Mal.
* Fröhliche Musik *
In der Tierpraxis in Rolle hat
Gwennaëlle alle Hände voll zu tun.
Ihre Chefin ist weg,
sie ist die einzige Tierärztin.
Sie darf die Nerven nicht verlieren,
auch bei mehreren Notfällen nicht.
Plötzlich sassen acht Leute
mit ihren Tieren im Wartezimmer.
Als ich kurz
in die Sprechzimmer geschaut habe,
standen in jedem drei Katzenkäfige.
Ja, ja. Ganz ruhig.
Da wird man schon nervös.
Bei einer Katze Blutabnahme,
eine andere wird geröntgt,
dann zurück zur ersten,
weil man etwas vergessen hat.
Ich bekam Panik. Aber man darf
nicht den Kopf verlieren.
Die Verantwortung und der Stress
sind extrem.
Das kann man auch nicht beschreiben.
Ein kleiner Dackel wartet geduldig
auf dem Schoss seines Frauchens,
bis er an der Reihe ist.
Ich wohne in Dully.
Ich bin
wegen meines Hundes Gypsy hier.
Er ist zwar klein,
aber sein Verhalten ist das
eines Deutschen Schäferhundes.
Viele trauen sich nicht mehr zu uns,
weil er so bellt.
Das ist unvorstellbar -
sofern er nicht krank ist.
Grüezi, Gwennaëlle Menoud,
Tierärztin.
Ja, hallo. Salut, Gypsy.
Schauen wir uns an,
was nicht gut ist?
Gehen wir nach hinten.
Voilà.
Er ...
Er kippt auf die Seite,
weil er das Gleichgewicht verliert.
Er frisst nicht mehr.
- Okay.
Er zittert.
Kam das ganz plötzlich?
Gestern konnte er noch springen?
- Ja.
Auch jetzt: Er stellt die Pfoten
nicht richtig ab.
Ich möchte am Boden schauen,
wie er läuft.
Komm.
Man sieht,
wie er mit dem Hinterteil schwankt,
weil er das Gleichgewicht verliert.
Er kann die Hinterpfoten
nicht richtig steuern.
Solche Gleichgewichtsstörungen könn-
ten ein neurologisches Problem sein.
Ich möchte ihn genauer abtasten.
Er zieht die Pfoten nicht nach.
Das deutet auf Schmerzen hin
oder auf ein neurologisches Problem.
Gypsys Reflexe sind zu langsam.
Ein gesundes Tier
stellt die Pfoten sofort richtig ab.
Bei neurologischen Problemen,
wenn die Hinterbeine betroffen sind,
muss man an die Bandscheibe denken.
Bei einem Bandscheibenvorfall
verrutscht die weiche Masse,
die zwischen den Wirbelkörpern liegt,
und drückt auf einen Nerv.
Das löst extreme Schmerzen aus.
Da?
Ich sah, dass er
an der Wirbelsäule Schmerzen hat.
Nach den Rippen, im Bereich
der Brust- und Lendenwirbelsäule.
Das ist ein klares Zeichen,
dass es schmerzt.
Hast du Schmerzen?
Jagdhunde sind besonders tapfer.
Aber als ich
die Wirbelsäule abtastete,
drehte er sofort den Kopf
nach hinten.
Gypsy muss genauer untersucht werden.
Das Röntgenbild zeigt nichts.
Aber um ein Bandscheibenproblem ab-
klären zu können, braucht's ein MRI.
Für die Magnetresonanztomographie
ist die Praxis nicht eingerichtet.
Es gibt nur eine Tierklinik
in der Romandie, die das macht.
Gwennaëlle ruft sofort an.
Grüezi, Gwennaëlle Menoud
von der Tierpraxis in Rolle.
Wir haben einen Langhaardackel,
Jahrgang 2008.
Ich vermute ...
Leider ist in den nächsten Tagen
für Gypsy kein Gerät frei.
Aber so lange kann man nicht warten,
weil sich der Zustand
verschlechtern könnte.
Es ist ziemlich dringend.
Endlich findet sie einen Platz,
im Tierspital Bern.
Das bedeutet 1 1/2 Std. Fahrt.
Grüezi.
Damit es schneller geht,
erklärt Gwennaëlle dem Neurologen,
worum es geht.
Es ist ein Dackel. Er hat Schmerzen
im Bereich der Lendenwirbelsäule.
Ja, ich weiss, es ist spät.
Ja, klar.
Es wäre besser, wenn er bereits
heute Nachmittag kommen könnte.
Dann können Sie morgen
das MRI machen.
Okay, vielen Dank. Auf Wiederhören.
Er kann heute noch nach Bern.
Das ist der nächste Neurologe.
Jetzt müssen wir alles vorbereiten:
Röntgenbilder, Blutanalyse.
Das ganze Team hilft mit,
die Unterlagen zusammenzustellen,
eine DVD mit Röntgenbildern,
Ergebnisse der Blutprobe.
Da die Schmerzmittel wirken,
frisst Gypsy wieder.
Gwennëlle schreibt den Report.
Der Hund muss rasch nach Bern.
Bei einem Bandscheibenvorfall
können schnell Lähmungen auftreten.
Komm.
Eine Diskushernie muss man
je nach Befund entweder operieren
oder mit Schmerzmittel
und Physiotherapie behandeln.
Ich wollte es abklären,
aber sie können nicht versprechen,
das MRI und die neurologischen
Abklärungen heute machen zu können.
Es ist schon spät.
D.h., ich muss schneller
als 120 fahren?
Nein.
- 122? - Nein.
120.
Voilà. Okay.
- Dann fahren wir los.
Vielen Dank.
Ich halte Sie auf dem Laufenden.
Alles Gute,
einen schönen Nachmittag.
In Bern kommt raus,
dass es kein Bandscheibenvorfall ist.
Vermutlich ist Gypsy
beim Spazieren blöd hingefallen.
Diesen Moment
mögen die Tierärzte am liebsten:
Wenn die Besitzer ihre Tiere
wieder abholen.
Für William ist es jedes Mal
wie eine Belohnung.
Grüezi.
Das haben wir gut hinbekommen.
Der Hund kann heute nach Hause.
Darum verabschiede ich mich.
Gute Zeit.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Auch Simone sitzt noch im Wartesaal
und kann es kaum erwarten.
Sie erhielt positiven Bescheid:
Leos Blutprobe zeigt, dass er
kein böses Virus in sich trägt.
Sein schlechter Zustand
war eine Reaktion auf eine Impfung.
... dass alles
so gut herausgekommen ist.
Wir wussten es nicht.
- Ich bin glücklich.
Happy End.
Wir sind froh,
dass er schon heute nach Hause darf.
Als er hier ankam,
waren wir beunruhigt.
Wir sind froh, dass es
viel positiver herausgekommen ist.
Oh, so schön.
Du bist da.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Er zittert.
Braver Hund.
Oh, hoppla.
Auf Wiedersehen.
In den nächsten Folgen:
Eléonore
muss einen Hengst kastrieren,
der etwas anders ist
als andere Männchen.
Es ist Alpaka Gaby.
Sie versucht es mit
der gleichen Technik wie bei Hunden.
Aber bei Gaby sieht alles anders aus.
- Ist ja winzig.
William kümmert sich um Jasmin,
der mit gelähmten Beinen
eingeliefert wird.
Wenn wir nicht eingreifen,
wird er seine Hinterbeine verlieren.
Eine Reha
wie für ein Spitzensportler.
Für die Französische Bulldogge
ist nur das Beste gut genug.
Und tatsächlich lernt sie,
ihre Hinterbeine wieder zu brauchen.
Gwennaëlle geht nach Belgien,
um in einem Tierspital zu arbeiten.
Zu ihren ersten Patienten
gehört das Huhn Whizzy.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Doucement.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Sabine Näpflin - 2020